I'm joined today by Gordon Whitman who's
deputy director of faith in action he's
also author of the book stand up how to
get involved speak out and win in a
world on fire this is a very interesting
issue to me Gordon because we've seen
particularly in light of the current
administration a lot of new interest and
new voices sort of enter the political
discussion but with a pretty significant
amount of frustration in many cases that
they're sort of unable to really affect
change or be activists in a way that
will influence the world around them so
the idea of exploring the best ways for
people to be engaged and to impact the
world around them is a really important
one what do you see as sort of the
primary limitations that might lead to
some people feeling as though their
voices are not really relevant yeah it's
interesting David I think we don't
always have enough organizations to
contain the energy that exists and then
sometimes those organizations aren't are
build and built and organized well
enough to really take that that desire
that people have to make change and give
them an outlet for it so it has been a
remarkable year the number of people
who've become involved in politics
I talked to a woman in Annapolis
Maryland who told me she was spending 70
hours a week
sharing her or leading her individual
chapter and first time involved in
politics or grassroots activity in her
life and there's thousands of people in
that position and and I think you know
it's been a remarkable year but we need
more organizations and they need to be
better organized and that's really what
I try to capture in and stand up and
I've worked as a community organizer for
about 25 years so really trying to
capture that that learning about you
know how do you make meetings work
better and be more useful for people's
time and how do you think about how
someone becomes a really a leader of
change in their own community that's
interesting because when one says as you
do that at least part of the issue is
lack of organization that in a way
suggests that it's actually not a
systemic problem that our political
system is conceivably set up in a way
that all of these newfound activists
sort of that have been created over the
last fourteen months or so that they
actually could be having a greater
impact if only they organized themselves
better what about the other side of it
which is sort of the way that the system
is designed to maintain the status quo
in the structures of power well yeah
David I think that's correct that you
know we have a constitution that you
know we're taught to revere but it was
created to make change extraordinarily
difficult and it's no accident that it
was written mostly by men who owned
slaves and wanted to maintain a status
quo and we can see the levels of
frustration that people feel you know
throughout history and certainly now but
why is it so hard to get Congress to act
on things that the American people
support and I think it's built into our
structure the size of our country the
diversity that changed there are a lot
of obstacles to change given that you
know what usually works and it takes
time is for people to organize
themselves effectively and I do think
it's the thing we have the most control
over to build better organizations you
know not just talk to people are
involved but be willing to go out knock
on people's doors reach people aren't
already part of some kind of social
change effort and and invite them in and
I don't think we're doing enough of that
to take one issue that you would you
would have thought at the time at least
would have been sort of a simple
political issue to solve which was in
the wake of the Sandy Hook Matthew in
Connecticut there was somewhere between
85 and 90 percent support for what we
would call universal background checks
for any gun sale whether it's at a gun
show between two people any situation a
background check must be done
overwhelming support from Democrats and
even from a majority of Republicans on
that issue didn't get it done just did
you know and there's a couple there's a
couple things people point to one would
be well yes but the gun lobby has such
financial influence that it was an issue
of the the status quo as we talked about
others say no those people needed to
better
organized in order to get that done how
do you assess that particular one yeah I
think that both things are true that you
know if if if Congress and any
legislature at state level was really
paying attention to what people want
we'd have a very different country so
you can go across the board whether it's
gun gun violence prevention and assault
weapon regulation to paid sick time to
minimum wage to you know so many issues
where the public supports a set of
policies and then we watch over and over
that legislators do the opposite and
that's you know the influence of money
is is tremendous and it's driving a lot
of what happens in Washington and our
state capitals but I think the other
part is it is possible to overcome that
and that's part of what the book is
about is you know it would be nice or
wasn't so but but that's just you know
part of how this democracy works that it
depends on us and citizens how well we
organize and it is possible to build
organizing campaigns that change public
policy and you know we're watching right
now this whole controversy about the
shutdown what's going to happen to
dreamers that program daca that provides
legal status ability to go to school and
work and get driver's licenses for
immigrant youth that was really an
organizing campaign that at the time
when immigrant youth stood up and said
we're here we're not going anywhere
we're not afraid and we need protection
for ourselves and our parents and our
families you know people said well you
know you can't do that and and we can't
do this you know we can't do dakka dakka
was organizing campaign the young people
fought for and won and now it's as the
center of our politics so you look at
the accomplishments whether it's minimum
wage or um earned sick time or
protections food food safety
environmental protection those were
things that we achieved because people
were willing to get involved and often
they started in their local communities
and I think that's a piece we often miss
if we get caught up in what's happening
in Washington what's happening with the
president but a lot of the change we
need to see happen he's going to begin
by making our cities and our states exam
apples and then building pressure or
federal change in terms of tactics right
what do you believe has been shown to be
the most or some of the most effective
tactics when we are presented with you
know writing letters to elected
officials boycotts of different kinds
demonstrations rallies marches getting
involved in politics oneself whatever
write the full possible list what what
is your sense of the most effective
tactics for creating change yes so the
evidence says its face to face would
people have a direct stake making the
case now that that's not the only thing
that works but I tell story in the book
about uh about a group of people who
came back from being in the prison
system in California to living in
Richmond California we're trying to put
their lives back together and faced a
lot of obstacles to finding work and
housing and began to organize in their
in Richmond California to make it easier
for people to find work and put their
you know get their lives back on track
and ultimately became involved in an
effort to reduce violence in the city
and then made the case that the city
didn't need a bigger jail it needed drug
treatment and job opportunities for
people who were in the criminal justice
system so they accomplished a lot in
their City and really made their City a
model getting the city to decide not to
build a bigger jail but to put that
money into education and drug treatment
instead and then that example really
became a major part of a statewide
campaign to move resources from the jail
system to the education system in the
state and I think that's how it you know
those were a lot of face to face
organizing where people who knew the
issue when it met with decision makers
when necessary to held rallies maybe
they engaged in civil disobedience so
that you can use a lot of tactics but it
begins when people have a most at stake
really standing up and saying you know
change is possible this is what we need
we we know we know this you know we know
this system we've had experience and and
meet directly with the
Maker's is there any value either
directly or by virtue of how it might I
guess engage new people of signing
online petitions sharing online
petitions you know there's some online
campaigns that have been very successful
groups like Color of Change have really
impacted corporate policies through
online campaigns so they have a role to
play but if you look at both what
happens today and in the past usually
it's groups and engage people
face-to-face but we have a lot of the
organization I work for it's a national
network Nathan Action used to be called
Pico we have a lot of research on what
helps people get involved and stay
involved and take greater leadership
it's almost always the face-to-face
opportunity to be with another person
and tell your story and build a close
trusted relationship with other people
in your community who share common
interests and then be able to go meet
with and directly confront people in
positions of power that are making
decisions so you know rallies online
petitions there are all tactics and have
a role to play but they need to be based
on organizations that people are
actually members of and we've lost touch
with that membership you know now you're
a member of an organization because they
have your email address and they send
you emails or you sign an online
petition but you're not really a member
of an organization unless you're meeting
with other people who are also members
and that social media doesn't does it do
away with the necessity for that kind of
grassroots face-to-face community civic
engagement Gordon do you share my
frustration and I know that it's not the
most useful frustration in terms of
being forward-looking but the
frustration I have that if only a
fraction of these newly engaged
individuals had just voted in November
of 2016 that a lot of this just wouldn't
happen when it came down to
seventy-seven thousand votes in three
states that are not historically very
red states that does do you share that
frustration and does that frustration
have some kind of place in figuring out
our future plans yeah I think we should
be frustrated that everyone's not voting
and and it would we
live in a very different country I think
we won we need to be clear that he's a
very intentional effort over the last
decade to make it much more difficult
for people to vote yeah
and that's been systematic it's been
focused primarily on on black and Latino
voters and it's been just very
pernicious from closing voting sites in
certain communities to requiring IDs and
then making it difficult to obtain them
you know we're just seeing a very
systematic effort to make it harder for
people to vote and and that doesn't
affect everyone but if it affects you
know 1% or 2% of voters who maybe don't
drive so now I'm driver's licenses you
can affect the outcome of an election
which is why that's been such a big
focus of efforts to try to hold on to
power particularly among conservatives
so I think you know let's pay attention
to that and then you know people vote in
part because the election is relevant
for them and and I think we fail when we
don't make the election relevant when we
don't have issues on the ballot when we
don't have candidates that are really
speaking to what people care most about
and then it's just hard work to motivate
people to vote and you know primarily
people vote because other people they
know are voting so my organization in
2016 through our local affiliates had
800,000 conversations with voters who
don't usually vote and what we find is
that if you have those conversations you
engage people at their doors and their
congregations in their communities
people are much more likely to vote but
we need to do more of that and you know
that's the big question is is this
August resistance and protest marches do
they translate into political power and
that that requires creating organization
and that's really our challenge right
now it's to build organizations that
people can be part of can lead and use
to govern their communities the book is
stand up how to get involved speak out
and win in a world on fire we've been
speaking with the book's author Gordon
Whitman really appreciate you talking to
me about this Gordon Thanks